the ultimate girl boss elizabeth holmes
guilty how many counts she got convicted
on four counts i don't know she got the
same voice as army hammer
scary in federal prison elizabeth
yeah elizabeth holmes elizabeth
elizabeth holmes yeah dude she got
convicted or uh conspiracy to commit
fraud against investors and three
charges of wire fraud and each one of
those carries a minimum of like 20 years
in prison i think yeah doesn't that mean
she's gonna go to club fed what's that
like federal prison like isn't that like
i think so yeah the white collar crime
dudes like isn't club fed like kind of
nice oh
yeah you need an nft to get into that
yeah yeah she'll be out there with
martin shkreli playing basketball and
dude imagine going to club fed and then
you come out smarter and a better
business person because you interact
with all these guys that did fraud
you're there with dan balzarian's dad
yeah you're like a ace at chess too yeah
grand master i've been playing a [ __ ]
ton of chess do you like it yeah i love
it but i suck ass
you know what's funny dude did you know
that all these chess grand masters are
like twitch superstars [ __ ] wild it's
such a rabbit hole i like so funny i
watched one chess video on youtube and
now my whole recommendation
is chess people and these twitch chess
stars like you just unlocked they're
like oh you're into chess well here's a
whole world yeah it's pretty wild i had
no idea and then i fell into that uh i
was watching charlie and xqc play with
magnus carlsen and that was like a year
ago and i was like damn i'm just
catching up now yeah yeah no chess was i
mean still is you know it gets hot on
twitch um
you play chess i
learned and i just know like the
standard opening but um i'm not very
good but i like it
it's so fun yeah it's a good game yeah
yeah when they came out of chess they
knew they were doing man it's classic
yeah whoever invented chess they knew
what the [ __ ] was going on